hello and welcome to WWDC 2016 the
future of Apple is emojis just joking
kind of I will just spent two hours at
its worldwide developers conference
announcing all sorts of updates to its
four major operating systems you didn't
wash it off don't worry I did here's
what you need to know number one iOS 10
it's coming to your iPhone and iPad this
fall and it should make your core apps
and Siri a lot better Apple it's opening
up Siri to work with third-party apps so
soon you'll be able to ask Siri to get
you a car or send a message through
another service I need to send a message
to Nancy via WeChat saying I'll be five
minutes late and I could do that in all
sorts of different languages plus the
music and news apps have been given a
much-needed redesign and now like Google
Photos Apple photos will let you search
by subjects in a photo the thing I'm
most excited about messages and emojis
and stickers there's emoji predictions
the ability to enlarge emojis you can
even tap a word to sub it for an emoji
plus there are stickers which are like
emojis on steroids number two Mac OS the
new version called Sierra finally
includes Siri tab on the Siri I con and
the interface will appear in the corner
you can ask Siri questions as usual but
you can also help with finding files and
searching the web and screw passwords
the Mac is also getting an auto unlock
feature that lets you unlock your
computer using an Apple watch sadly it
doesn't work with your iPhone number
three watch OS 3 it's coming to Apple
watches this fall and it should make
these things a lot faster apple says the
watch will be seven times faster of
course I'll have to test that it's also
adding new fitness features including
the ability to compete against friends
and family on steps and workouts oh and
yes there's a new Minnie Mouse watch
face last but not least TV OS it gets
the most incremental updates this time
around but there's still some new
interesting features Siri will be able
to search for movies TV shows and
finally YouTube videos single sign-on
will also make logging into apps easier
you'll only have to log in with your
cable TV's username and password once
those are the highlights but really
it's about emojis either way Apple
certainly set the stage for hardware
announcements this fall